hallo mein name ist luca und damen und
herren ihr seht es bereits dort hinten
eingeblendet der das liest ist doof spaß
beiseite ich meine lieben freunde ihr
seht es bereits im titel heute kommen
tatsächlich mal wieder e-mails mit lukas
bin ich haue ich weiß dass ich in der
ebay fels folge vor einer woche schon
gesagt habe dass das die letzte folge
sein wird aber wir haben noch mal
ordentlich sachen rausgesucht nicht
jeder bock drauf habt dass eventuell
noch eine allerletzte folge kommen der
lasten like da unter diesem video
einfach einen daumen hoch geben und ich
würde sagen wir fangen jetzt auch direkt
an mit der ersten anzeige verkaufe
dieses handy also der ebay user
verkaufte er sein handy für 150 euro und
das hier das ist das komplette angebot
er schreit handy ist nicht im bild da
ich es für foto machen gebraucht habe es
ist so lange und so breit dass er keine
bilder von dem handy sondern nur von
seinen fingern weil er ja
verständlicherweise das handy für die
bilder gebraucht hat das ist zumindest
nicht gelogen ihr kennt ja mit
sicherheit dieses märchen wo dann der
frosch zu einem könig wird ich glaube
das heißt froschkönig auf jeden fall
verkauft hier jemand einen prinz zum
selberbauen ok einen frosch einfach nur
küssen und der frosch wird zu einem
prinzen hieß das märchen doch frosch
prinz ist aber auch egal ich würde sagen
wir machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten ebay feld und zwar mit diesem
hier dem bausatz für edeka töte das ist
einfach eine zerrissene edeka pub tüte
die er hier verkauft in die beschreibung
schreibt er habe leider die anleitung
verloren am besten zu verkaufen
als gläubiger als klavier schreiten
allerdings direkt voran zudem nächsten
die wehr angebot und zwar zu einer birne
allerdings keine normalen gene sondern
einer sehr seltenen birne für 500 euro
gibt es die und in der beschreibung
steht diese birne ist schon fünf mal
runter gefallen und somit unglaublich
selten ein solches exemplar jemals zu
erwerben ist sehr selten
also muss ganz ehrlich sagen in der
woche das hier ist das nächste angebot
und zwar verkauft hat jemand seinen
roller und er wollte eigentlich in den
titel schreiben ohne papier ohne
schlüssel mehr schreibt allerdings ohne
papiere und schlüssel
aber hey 500 euro in den nächsten über
angebot wollte glaube ich jemand sein
bett verschenken
normalerweise schreibt man anhalt bett
verschenken den tippelt geschrieben ich
schenke dem bett ein geschenk da ist das
geld auf jeden fall sehr dankbar glaube
ich hier verkauft jemand ein kritisches
lama für 700 euro
das lama ist mein haustier hat jura
studiert und arbeitet als richter beim
oberlandesgericht
da kaufe er ist weil es mich einfach
ständig belehren will mit irgendwelchen
gesetzen und mich immer wenn ich einen
fehler mache so anguckt es kann
mitgenommen werden gegen eine
schutzgebühr von 700 euro
aber sonst geht es dir gut dicker als
nächstes verkaufte jemand eine nintendo
switch neuwertig für 250 euro es ist
eine kaum genutzte nintendo switch
üblichen gebrauchsspuren nichts
besonderes und ohne spiele und
controller oder kabel
es geht also nur um die switch neuwertig
und das ist das foto die ist definitiv
neuwertig deger hier verkauft jemand
kartoffelknödel und schreibt in die
beschreibung ich habe dreimal
kartoffelknödel aber ich brauche das
nicht preis ist einfach nicht vorhanden
also ich würde die nehmen machen
allerdings direkt weiter mit einem
technik produkte und zwar einem laptop
für die frau der laptop kann im
normalfall von jeder frau intuitiv
bedient werden keine verhandlungsbasis
und das hier ist der laptop
ich sehe da eher ein waffeleisen aber
okay ihr kennt ja mit sicherheit die
filmreihe die minions das sind diese
gelben figürchen die rumlaufen ein
bisschen trottelig sind die zelltherapie
p hier verkauft jemand den film und
benennt das angebot die mini und mini
vans ja sollte der richtige name hier
verkauft wird als nächstes einen soliden
händedruck und zwar schreibt er die
beschreibung wir können uns auch vor ort
treffen und ich schüttel dir die hand
ich kann sie dir auch je nach nachfrage
brechen oder küssen der preis bleibt
versand nicht möglich ja das wäre auch
ziemlich komisch wenn der versand
möglich wäre dann würde ich einfach nur
eine abgehackte hand bekommt
menschenrechte sind sämtlich abstoßen
das hier ist die nächste anzeige und
zwar ist ein ecken hammer ich biete hier
einen formschönen einzigartigen ecken
hammer an dieser ermöglicht es ihnen in
zukunft ohne probleme die nägel auch um
die ecke einzuschlagen
also da kann man echt klatschen in
meinen augen ist es eigentlich ein
kaputter hamm hat aber man kann
natürlich auch eckenheimer nennen beim
nächsten ebay will ich euch wirklich
einfach nur stumpf das angebot zeigen
uns war das hier
ich suche leute die auch in der woche
bock haben sich mal ordentlich ein paar
bierchen rhein zu löten als gläubiger
nun kommen wir allerdings wieder zu
einer richtig seltenen anzeige auf die
bei uns was es wieder ein nahrungsmittel
und zwar ein käse chip in form von super
mario
also freunde da für dich wirklich direkt
zugreifen bleibe allerdings direkt beim
essen meine lieben freunde hier verkauft
jemand den
ein paar der welt der ist so groß 15
stück und da bin ich ganz ehrlich ich
kenne keinen kleineren pomberg kommen
überhaupt kennen die pumpen werde
überhaupt oder bin ich der einzige der
die kennt und wo wir jetzt schon zwei
ebay anzeigen mit dem thema nahrung
hatten bleiben wir auch direkt dabei und
zwar hier verschenkt jemand einen flip
mit der begründung ich verschenke diesen
flip von 2009 weil ich kein platz in
meiner sammlung habe es fällt mir sehr
schwer weil er ein sehr besonderer flip
ist echt toll wenn ich sowas lese weiter
geht's mit einem hörspiel meine lieben
freunde und zwar eigentlich aufgrund der
jetzigen situation gar nicht mal so
lustig und zwar ist ein hörspiel vom
glöckner von notre dame die meisten
unter euch werden es mitbekommen haben
die notre dame ist vor einigen tagen ein
wenig abgebrannt das meiste steht noch
aber aufgrund von bauarbeiten hat er
wahrscheinlich denke ich mal einfach
irgendeine kippe hingeschmissen und dann
ist halt ziemlich viel von diesem
kunstwerk von dieser riesigen kirche
abgefackelt allerdings möchte ich euch
dennoch diesen ebay fällt hier nicht
vorenthalten und zwar nennt er dieses
produkte der glöckner von notre dame
apropos dame und zwar hat der erste
fußballclub köln gestern gegen darmstadt
verloren in der zweiten bundesliga und
als die verloren haben
da fand bei mir auch ordentlich was im
darmstadt machen wir allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten die befehle und
zwar verschenkt hier jemand hundehaare
also
ich frag mich echt ob es nicht
vielleicht wirklich sogar leute gäbe die
sich denken würden auch mit den haaren
könnte ich doch ne super deko basteln so
ein kandidat wer beispielsweise meine
mutter also die kann alles irgendwie
wieder verwerten wobei allerdings gerade
schon beim thema mutter sind was eine
beschissene überleitung hat hong für den
versand der schwiegermutter
dieser typ verschenkt hier wirklich
einen menschen großen karton mit dem man
seine unbeliebte schwiegermutter zitat
in die antarktis verschiffen kann also
die kreativität von einigen nutzern die
müsste wirklich mal ausgezeichnet werden
wir machen nun allerdings nicht weiter
mit einem ebay angebot von einem
verkäufer sondern von einem käufer und
zwar schreibt er ferrari lamborghini
supersportwagen geschenkt da denkt man
sich erstmal hey vielleicht verschenkt
er jetzt irgendwie sein auto nie genau
das gegenteil ist der fall suche einen
gelangweilten supersportwagen fahrer der
seinen ferrari gerne auch lamborghini
nicht mehr benötigt und verschenken will
bin gerne bereit ihn auch direkt vor ort
abzuholen bitte alles anbieten freue
mich von euch zu hören
melde dich wenn du einen hass ich würde
mich da auch anschließen da haben wir
allerdings direkt beim thema verschenken
und zwar geht hier dieser maulwurf
verschenkt und das witzige heran ist
eigentlich der titel und zwar steht dort
verstört drein blickender maulwurf an
tierfreunde abzugeben verstört
dreinblickend maulwurf vorher recht hat
hat er recht denn lesen ist etwas für
alle simpsons kenner unter euch und zwar
verschenkt sie jemand diese beiden
puppen also milhouse und bat die beiden
charaktere aus der simson serie nennt
die personen allerdings bot simpson
das ist richtig und dann nicht milhouse
sondern müll haus nun verkaufte jemand
einen mini marshmallow grill lka einfach
eine stinknormale kerze und kommen wir
nun jetzt allerdings auch zum letzten
ebay für die heutige folge bzw das
vielleicht für immer
wie gesagt wenn ihr wollt dass doch noch
vielleicht irgendwann ebay failed kommt
dann hast einen daumen hoch bei diesem
video hier da allerdings verschenkt hier
erst mal jemand seinen selbstständigen
hamster und zwar schreibt er in die
beschreibung er ist viel erfolgreicher
als ich und betreibt seine eigene bar
meine frau macht auch schon auge auf ihn
ich muss mich von ihm trennen bevor die
situation eskaliert
die kommen leute auf so was habe ich das
heute wird jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch das
heutige video hier gefallen hat dann
würde ich mich sehr sehr toll bei einem
daumen hoch von euch freuen uns wie
gesagt schreib mir unten in die
kommentare
ob ich noch einen weiteren teil ebay
fails hochladen soll wir sind fleißig am
recherchieren es gibt noch ganz ganz
ganz ganz viele fans aber wir wollen
auch einfach nicht irgendwas in die ich
sage die ganze zeit wir
juli sucht halt die sachen raus bereitet
mir die hier vor und ich reagiere halt
da drauf jetzt geht noch ganz ganz viele
sachen aber ich will halt eigentlich
nicht dass diese serie hier 20 partnern
wie du nicht einfach nur irgendwas rein
donner hier
was ich aber selbst nicht mehr lustig
finde qualität so ein bisschen über
quantität deswegen kommt das ja auch
noch alle 78 tage abonniert main kanal
falls doch keine von der zeit verpasst
sich keine videos mehr ist kostenlos
einfach um das video auf abonnieren
klicken und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]